okay it started to stream
seven
who wants water uh
oh sorry I'm [ __ ] slow
uh four
foreign
okay it's on the right of the van seven
yeah just knock on the doors unit two
five okay
[Laughter]
okay you have one already I'll be I'll
be eating red all right cool I'm so done
are we gonna get a quick tutorial on
what to do or should I just pretend like
I know think of it as a trial by fire
okay done I can do that fine
okay who wrote you rolled the high I
roll an eight yeah
does anyone want to sit out what
does anyone want to watch sit out maybe
for this turn because we got two more
people coming do you want me to sit out
for this so that way yeah you can still
sit here absolutely also just like watch
How to yeah yeah you can still sit here
yeah no I think that's probably gonna if
there's somebody actually knows what
they're doing all right cool we just
need how long are the games
40 minutes maybe okay
oh that's about that so now it's
jamisha's turn so the way the game is
played is you try to hey
do you want to explain it to them's
Kareem or yeah what's up oh my God
everyone's bringing beers tonight
[Music]
so Hans are there any more chairs
downstairs
okay
so can you see the card of like things
you need to build people like those
things
[Music]
well we need to find a chair let me go
ask a son I mean it's in my blood
all right can I buy it oh thanks
for the numbers with more stool
s.com
you can perch and then you also want to
be
[Music]
Paul doesn't know how to play it's like
items sure here uh you can sit right
here I feel you did yeah
I feel like we should dab right now do
you want me to sit together are they
polished
because you know how to play right
a little bit
okay just scoot in a little bit so that
we can see it on the camera
[Music]
okay
did you say you're a dad
I'm not a dead
company do you want me to do you guys
need to switch with your plan nope all
right
so what do you think about Kanye West
what's happening I don't really ever
think about them
thing too though
is it because you're right
he's still in your hat
I don't know what's happening it's like
the workout
usually the question he asks so what do
you guys think about the Austin Texas oh
Jesus
they could like
I like uh sandpaper yeah
the top of my mouth hurts a lot yeah
that's part of it the Captain Crunch of
candy part of the thrill is the pan
that's what I say the last
of them and I thought only the gummy
portion of it had the THC but it turns
out that the uh the actual nerds did too
so did you first just go like this like
like kind of like try to yeah because I
thought that was because I thought that
was the part without the teeth
I was trying to just eat the dinner
uh but both the Nerds and he wrote
that's hilarious contaminated
and I was not doing okay and that's fine
did you get pretty stoned
I was not doing okay
fair fair
he's like how's that possible how do you
get it into the nerd
damn now I want some nerds
yeah you ever seen Jennifer's Body yeah
she drooling
thanks
online somewhere I just saw it
yeah well yeah it's one of my favorite
brand is somewhere on there we just
understand I didn't see that one but
they had like a bunch of Pulp Fiction
movies that they did the same like oh
cool yeah they're cool
thank you so uh whose turn is it cool
shirt I believe she's putting down
so the way you play the game is that you
want to put a settlement on a Vertex yep
and then if you put a settlement on the
vertex you get all the resources
connected to it so the more dots that
are under the number the more valuable
it is okay so this vertex is five plus
three plus two so this is five or ten
dots
so you want to pick a spot with a lot of
dots like this is a lot of dots this is
five nine three but you also want yeah
but you also want a diverse group of
resources not all the same things this
is how you build things it's with these
resources
okay cool thanks all right shout out
from San Antonio
take care take your settlement back okay
uh you got to put down a road too you
gotta point it somewhere not you jamisha
you got to point a road somewhere you
got to build a road so yeah the roads
are the longest skin I'm gonna put it
there and then grab a road I did grab a
road and you said
yeah Jimmy show you and then you put it
down anywhere I was talking to dang I
put down a road
oh okay can I go yeah
then you can build another one okay
there it is
so what do you guys think about Kanye
West
what a crazy man right he's very
very I think he's wrong about a lot of
things
including the Jews
that you're saying you need to go far
enough
I think that he has some controversial
opinions
oh that Beyonce should have won that VMA
yeah
and it's ten years ago
did you guys see that interview with uh
him and Lex Friedman yeah my brother's
obsessive
it's crazy I have nothing against I
think Lex did a good job of uh kind of
pushing him on some hard like harder
questions
yeah because he's gotten some slack in
the back for not like pushing back
enough and I think he's like changed
that yeah in recent future it's standing
up to Kanye West will see a good
exercise
oh yeah
well Hans you've been standing up to
Kanye for years now
it's been a silent protest yes
exactly which spoke volumes
it's all about those dots those dots
you gotta gobble up them dots and then
the city lets you double up the dots
okay
so then you get double of everything
cool
dots
double dots
so you have to put down twice right last
oh yeah yeah
I didn't think about that damn I'm done
the 3D printed this little guy
um
Dylan you're a genius it is I learned
something when I was young he was smart
you is
he was baking your [ __ ] into white
people's food exactly yeah that was the
theme of the movie
you're doing very well I need everything
I can get damn it I wish I would have
played somewhere else
is the settlement down since I wish I
was smart enough to know right like I
would have I would have laid it down
differently but okay
hey
it's the worst one
all right oh hey we'll have its day
hey what happens we'll call it heyday
heyday
hey there
okay building costs
y'all are like reading y'all are messing
around right now I'm I'm a lyricist
s
man it was free on Craigslist
some lady was giving it away
they'll do that sometimes
all right she called in her son to help
us move this is amazing it's free and
Craigslist free
and it even has the plug on it those are
wild I'm never like school I don't think
I'd ever be nice enough to take the time
to put something else free I would
literally just dump it illegally
probably somewhere like I would never be
like hey I don't want to pay to get rid
of this yeah so I'm gonna have you pick
it like no I would just throw it out
goodbye I mean it's a pain in the ass to
throw away something this big that's
true do you need help moving it to
incentivize it that's true you meet cool
people too when you buy their [ __ ] you
know yeah you meet you meet people you
get an organizations
it works
oh I didn't take it the first time I
went to the organization okay yeah
I was in Chicago put the mic on
yeah
you don't have to I didn't know this was
part of it by the way I know I should
have told you
I didn't realize
I want to do a comedy show like a
baseball player in Oregon yeah
what do I look for a mic
uh
they could at least try every time okay
and then you get all the resources
whose turn is this it's mine I think you
should have fun
you can't go right here right here right
yes
I've gone once okay
okay
yeah it's your turn first and then your
turn and then say sorry yeah oh yeah
yeah we're going this way
[Music]
oh crap that would have been better that
would have been better
that's not necessarily a good thing
oh break
sorry okay sheep
sheep yeah
actually so let's turn them over okay
and that was jamisha's turn now it's
true
and we weren't supposed to grab him for
the first round no okay
all right I know the game now you know
nothing yeah
whoa
okay don't take my next you should you
shut the [ __ ] up
right here right that was my spot I
don't care yeah it has to be two away so
you could go on this one if you want
yeah okay that's not that good yeah but
it's sort of good then you're like
smoked yeah
my goal is to be on the five so now I'm
not gonna go in there anymore
those are some high numbers High numbers
over here I'm gonna
don't buy this forever dude
that could be good that works right here
we go there we go
and then you build a road yeah
yeah and then you get a wheat a sheep
and a brick because they're touching all
the all those resources
go ahead and go ahead yeah
and wheat
oh he's got the uh the thing I did
and we began
I love the games begin we call this a
tight board in the best a type
so there's a 10 here so Brown what's up
um
there if you want to just like look out
for your number
three
[Music]
yeah I feel you almost here someone's
getting two people are getting trees
over there
yeah you get two trees right okay
she's literally on yeah double trees
she's okay
okay got it all right Double Tree that
must have been the shortest meeting ever
I want to call it trees double it up
let's go home
I don't know let's take lunch
dude
[Laughter]
she's like building a home heritage
so whose turn is it James
oh yeah
okay so just keep going yeah
it's a bit of both all right this is
Koreans Kareem brought the shotgun
type of beer yeah they're supposed to be
range Waters but they taste like yeah so
so what's it okay six six so
that would be here that's a nine okay
and then right there
you see that six over there Dane did you
pick up the six because you're red right
oh yeah thank you okay yeah
uh yeah
paper six thank you we only have
strategy wood
no you should you should buy something
on the menu if you can okay because if
you have seven or more or if you have
more than seven cards then because then
it uh yeah that's what you can like when
somebody rolls you step half your card
gotcha okay now back
you go back in time again yeah I'm at
six I better buy something
it's
got a little mic
[Laughter]
where is the mic I don't know where the
mic is
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
go ahead and do it all right sick
Let's uh bam try the building over here
instead
okay let's play the entire
time can you tell me why so I know that
because it has to be two away so if you
build right here you're ready to build a
settlement if you build here you have to
build another road thank you another
settlement won't forget it thank you
Captain
future man to fish
Amanda Katan you roll the six right yeah
okay for
now you gotta roll first roll before you
do anything yeah okay
cool
oh wait Daddy okay got it
four
do I get wood
I get wood okay
yeah
since I went to just dress up around
like a table and you look and I was just
playing
does anyone have bones thousands of
dollars does anyone want to trade for a
brick
no does anyone have a brick that would
like to trade for what uh all the wood a
lot of wood
what about some heavy
[Music]
um I'm gonna build a road
um
over here
oh wait no it's not touchable okay yeah
it's got to be a settlement it can't
just be uh in the direct Direction
all right cool
okay I'm done
another eight six
wheat
yeah
um okay does anyone have a would anyone
like a or for a wood
or foreign
yes
okay Stones Rock Source yeah I didn't
realize cities cost a lot of ore
oh
wait are you guys are you interested in
listening what happened
that's now okay
yeah and I was like I thought I could do
one for one yeah yeah sure let's do it
good adventures
in for a brick
and then a tree and I'll build the road
you don't know that song I'm surprised
Colbert
no I listen like Dave Matthews I don't
really listen to it
hello I have a Dave Matthews Band tattoo
really yeah
I do I have the naked dancing girl but
you have the fire dancer yeah no way
yeah and like because you said you're
gonna be sitting there I love David
um
do you all go to Christian School okay
um
do you want to explain everyone count
your cards
under seven cards you have to then give
back half of them oh bummer and then I
get to move the robber guy to someone
and then take from someone right if that
number Hits they cannot pick up from
there so I'm going to go over to this
christmas-ass looking tree over here
dude and uh
so now
okay
thank you
no I do but if going with your manager
it's like such a weird
in the middle
is so extremely moderate
yeah
uh right here
I got it when I was at 16. really yeah
yes
everyone's sort of in the middle it's so
cool I wouldn't classify Joe Rogan as um
there's so many fans that just
yeah did you do all your things
even though he's on hey yeah don't have
two conversations at the same time
this doesn't affect me so okay I rolled
a12.
how about that
that didn't help anyone I don't think
anyone's on nope nope okay sorry do you
want to buy anything uh do I want to buy
anything
sorry hold on I'm about to purchase
something I will buy a road
oh yeah
what did you vote for today
well don't you think the only way to
make political changes have a lot of
money so what's the point of voting
three
five numbers no just one green person
does anyone have a um
can I have a wood [ __ ]
does anyone have a brick they want to
trade for wheat wood
is it
this is
um okay no I already gave you
eight eight
all right nothing
five
five
wait would you eight got a little brick
um
does anyone have a brick or a
tree and it gives you a wheat bread I
have
I have a wheat but that's very valuable
it is right
you want to break he's just passing
around bricks over there yeah you got a
bunch of bricks my brick to me is very
bad you want wood uh yeah do you still
have the rock yes
okay water for her eyes yes okay okay
all right
um
instead of breakfast
two rocks
no no way equation I'll give you a rock
for a brick yeah what about sheep
our pasture what is this you need a
sheep no I don't I got plenty of them
okay do you have a
do you have any bricks uh I do have a
brick but I need I need wheat
I'll I'll do that
cool
sold over here slain deals deal slinging
just gonna build it Road
is that a good trade
but green has one so
what is it you got it it's a 10. but I
think that's blocked the one next to it
also or no actually the red Brown has a
yeah he already picked it up okay
right does anybody want one of these
same yeah
two rocks all right
yeah I got them for two dollars and six
packs okay I'm gonna buy a development
card
s relinquished my turn
graciously God took it took a while
yeah
so
as I like to call it Mama's special
athletes
six
[Music]
okay
um I would also like to see if anybody
has any rocks
I have Rock I have rocks I could give
you
smoked rocks I could give you a hay and
a
vlog
a hand one you got a deal
you love to see it diplomacy yeah
calm down
um I'm going to
stir up in Africa trading with each
other calm down
I am Africa
are you like Elon Musk
South Africa
that is book that's Book of Mormon right
what is are you I've never seen that one
yet you're in that one I want to though
there's this song called I'm Africa and
it's all the like light really singing
the song yeah it's great is it like like
they sing yeah yeah
it's fair that I think I'm not a huge
guy fan of musicallys but I would love
that yeah
do you love musicals either yeah
like that look around that sounds so fun
this is so funny or it's on the card
that's a good question what kind of mic
am I looking for it's like a like a
stand-up mic
[Music]
I never got into my high school
that's one thing to be like in a High
School Musical but tonight
it does yeah I auditioned for it right
yeah
two roads
that's what I meant I'm sorry XLR
oh nice thank God yeah there should be
that solar over there
no that's not I'm gonna buy a
development card
whoa
yeah
what does that do
that's not teaching
she's new she's new as new as you are no
I'm not
about that cards means that
oh yeah
sorry I didn't get that it's like the
equivalent of getting a chance card in
Monopoly I'm gonna give you like
advantages cool
candy way
also with the development cards if you
get Three Robbers then you get two extra
points it's called largest army and then
also if you have the longest road out of
anyone then you get longest road which
is also two points hello stand-up
comedian Owen Benjamin how's everybody
doing
hey did you grab uh yes you did okay
cool here you go
this is better
okay sorry
ten another 10.
Lady Luck is a cruel mistress
[Laughter]
um no one talks does anyone have a brick
no yeah you have two rocks no
um you're you're two rocks right
I mean brick is pretty valuable the same
response every time it's called it's
called visualization and positive
affirmations is that the secret and
believing in yourself alternate okay
does anyone have a rock
music
half price what is this guy David of
Nazareth
got him oh it's flipped over yeah
uh can I do a development card yeah you
can yeah there you go
so ring of power anyone rings of power
on Amazon
it's booty it's awesome I love it
so bad it's not that why is it bad it's
not bad
like a billion dollars on it looks like
[ __ ] that's just the popular thing to
say he has no opinions of his own no oh
nine okay that's what everyone says but
I watched it it was good it was sugar
it's good I like it have you seen it
have you seen the whole thing here's
something I haven't even seen a single
second one yeah
I'm just trying to make good radio
this is why Trump won
is rings of power the Lord of the Rings
series or the Game of Thrones The Game
of Thrones is that defensive that I saw
the Game of Thrones is House of the
Dragon thank you the Lord of the Rings
one is ring of power okay so you like
rings of power I did why did some people
not like it I think because it was
trendy to not like and they're just like
we don't like the general direction of
I remember that there was like more
diversity in this one that people were
mad about that yeah I mean it was a
culture thing yeah but if you guys seen
the show rings of Lauer about Matt Lauer
have you guys heard of the songs
Johnny Cash is that or Mr door where is
the documentary of out loud or someone
should make that
everyone else I remember what he did not
lose stay in this chair he did he had
like a something on his desk that would
lock his door when women would come into
his office that was okay yeah I thought
that was Weinstein it might have been
him but anyways
the same thing good train it's funny
um any bricks out there nah okay did
they have an ombre who's Orange
I've passed out a couple brick in my day
I would like to use my knife
oh switched it up what what's that oh I
just move the thing and take a card
again go ahead
so who is winning the Robert
it's just I know like three cards
looks like the lights are land damn
white there's nothing you're always
winning the White
is right
now I will roll is that your new t-shirt
six
six
over there
can you just
giveaway you're great oh
yeah I relinquish my time
respectfully wow I respectfully exactly
what's the craziest
did you hear what they said they said
they would [ __ ] your [ __ ] a woman's face
out of respect
what do you say would you [ __ ] someone's
face out of respect
with respect in some religion that's a
proper burial and he [ __ ] her face for
you not for us and so we did the Osama
really um no they took like b-reels with
him oh no be real isn't out yet
we can fix this
make love to people's faces
what does that look like these are laugh
track it's very sensual
because my mother gave it to me in the
womb when I almost died
why don't you just not nose [ __ ] are you
trading hold on okay well sorry if I had
been your friend before it happened you
would have told me that what do I need
to hear the strong medical role model of
my life
where did you just get that card where
did that Target that was a development
card right thank you
they did six six again
some [ __ ] blocking it
dude I need the brick so bad this is
ridiculous
I have too many sheets can I just start
killing Coke too so it's like wait would
you roll are you itching a six okay
Orange
I want to grab something
do you want nine sheep for one week
also you can you can trade four of
anything for whatever card you want
or uh yeah
that's right hold on did you go yet no
oh my God and if you build on these
ports they have like three for one super
one yeah
share that please
oh my god
with respect yeah it was only the ninth
time where I was like 25 years all right
perfect thank you okay okay uh if I have
a development card do I do it first or a
roll first whatever you want whatever
okay I'm gonna move the night
um
same thing okay hey Paul do you have any
more of those no yeah
dude I got these for like 250. the
Crusaders were animals
they write 10 pillars
it's horrible yeah I'm leaving them here
absolutely terrible
[Laughter]
what is your thoughts on the Crusaders
appreciate it
um I'm going it wasn't good oh so who do
I take from either one you want oh who
has more
it's all a matter of opinion
take from the white man
[Music]
I was born this person with the most
points it makes sense you know who and
he has three so he's winning three yeah
I mean what are points
whatever I want points are about how
many sheep you have points or barriers
I'm taking this oh let's play mini golf
with a friend that didn't want to keep
score a few months ago
she sounds crazy was she a liberal
uh oh yeah is she vaccinated
how many times a day do you say
a lot
of Nancy Pelosi can I do two and then a
settlement or you can build a settlement
right now you can build one right here
give me a little historical background
okay Crusaders are you history Buffs the
Crusaders were a bunch of Crusaders can
I have a background of the regulator I
can't pull them out what are you talking
about huh I'm already talking about you
asked what you asked me like a
definition no not about the Crusaders
like right before you yeah
oh yeah not keeping score yeah
it's totally fine like if you want to
keep score then you should be allowed
yeah
no one good ever doesn't want to wait
let's show me that you're crazy oh it's
always bad what are you talking about
to use to make videos to Rick Reuben
yeah we make a bunch of songs me and my
jam band we make a bunch of songs about
Rick Rubin
we have a bunch of diss tracks about
Rick Rubin eight eight and we have a
bunch of apology tracks
eight anyone have an eight
no I just picked up yeah I get some
brick yes
what uh why do you like red roses yes
correct
huh
why do you like Rick Rubin so much
musical genius
iCal penis he's a musical piece
he's a producer
yeah he produced uh like Beastie Boys
okay I like anybody whose last name is a
sandwich
does anyone have a freaking brick huh no
Matthew grilled cheese
I gotta break around here bricks bricks
anybody
to my girlfriend
I don't have a rock what no one's wrong
do you want a wheat instead I know I
have my wheat now I don't need you
I'll need weed later now talk to me
later but wait a second then I'll need
Rock too
okay this is rough I got I got a a rock
and a wheat for whoever coughs up a
brick
I don't have that brick anymore or my
rip
I don't know so I will even sweeten the
deal I'll do two rocks in a week done
oh three for one thank you
ah what an ass ah he's good at this no I
could have built a city
[Music]
um
it would have to be magnetized to
account for the bumpings damn you've
already thought about it
10
10.
or should I say wow
Brown is winning right now brown is
winning we should prevent that from
happening does anybody need a wheat for
paint like anything
like a sheep
sure
sure does anyone have a sheep for a week
stop training
I have you're winning I have time I have
two Woods it's a great deal
no one two Woods
no not sheep what are you looking like
no he needs a sheep I'll take your weed
being away house okay I'm good
you're the one in need
seven
Jesus Oh
TG here we go
uh
oh I'm eight now yeah you're right now
is there any more
wood over there yeah okay
oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry
again you're gonna have to move the
tripod a little bit
um does anybody have
that's good yeah
that looks nice
you can't even see it Dave looks like a
dude that should be on the WB you're
really a good like WWE I don't know
anything you guys keep saying stuff it's
called Warner Brothers I realize I know
I have no idea about me I'm an alien
what planet I am
says the background of Smallville the
Frog okay oh he'd be in the foreground
why would it be in the forest I don't
know if he could fit in the foreground
Australian head it's a C-section head
among other parts of his body yeah yeah
it's giant hog yeah we're gonna need
Dan's hog in the foreground of the shot
all right yeah
okay
how about I get a pick for her no yeah
why would you do that
so and that's the I got two watches on
shut up here's wow I noticed it outside
actually are they the same times UFC
fighter Sean O'Malley she watches a lot
whoa
yeah
you can take anything on you know
I could take on anyone Headstrong
so that means I can grab two sheep oh
God there's so much
[Laughter]
how many times
that's a podcast tomato have excitement
imagine like going okay I'm going to buy
something you want some excitement
hold on there
I'm gonna purchase a settlement
here's some excitement for you I need a
road now
um
thanks teacher JG Wentworth over here
okay you can go now okay
um
Is that real sterling silver yeah
[Music]
wait what
on top
it's called the game
no it's not fair thank you
um
g in it no it's not 50 Cent it's the
game
oh yeah
yeah it's from the same era the game's
mother or lesbian yes it's pretty cool
well we're both of their mothers
lesbians I mean somewhere along the way
50s was oh maybe it's for these oh
because he talks about it yeah Mama
kissing a girl yeah and uh hated her
love it yeah yeah
that album's incredible
what uh
yeah just Banger after Banger
and 50 and Eminem working together was
great yeah
who was the who was that guy they were
always talking [ __ ] about
did he die I don't know I don't know
I've never tried to talk [ __ ] about so
many people imagine walking around with
that like rain green sorry what'd you
get would you roll uh I'm sorry from oh
it was great I was telling the whole
seven thing
this makes sense
50 Cent challenge Floyd Mayweather to
read one page of a Harry Potter book I
don't remember this eight you
respectfully declined yeah
anybody gotta eat
eight do I get another brick I get a
freeze
good
there's nothing I can do
so who did you vote for right anyway I
thought we ended that conversations
let's go Beto is definitely gonna fix
some of the mistakes instead of making
them worse you think he's gonna win no
yeah do you think
he already lost according really
according to our political
correspondence thanks
[Music]
no chance for hope I like that
I'll at least have mystery during the
game
I like to get all my news shouted up a
flight of stairs that's the only way I
like to receive my news there's about
the Mavericks game
stuff not that you know I just bought
tickets to San Antonio's first they were
like 16 bucks each I had to look up how
bad the teams do this year but I only
can only assume that they are not good I
really respond turning respectful
I mean Beto was obviously how you run a
good country like Europe like there's a
way to do it like Sin City and running
it like a cowboy crazy person is the
wrong way to run it
all right
I just don't like how attractive my
girlfriend is tomatoes
oh Jesus
yeah I know that's why you know that's
what I said as I was putting it on but I
have to take this off I still see a
Hillary stair occasionally God damn
you're carrying the hell around
everywhere does anyone want to hay for a
row or excuse me for a wood two eggs
yeah would you roll done a four cool
I had my money on Gore like you know a
while ago
oh Andrew tank becomes president that's
what I think the next step in America
that's funny
Andrew take could never be president
because he's too irresponsible wow
that's what they said about Trump dude
yeah look how he turned out uh greatest
president of our entire lifetime yeah
killed a million people the lowest
told people to inject bleach
during a pandemic I mean who who Among
Us has it told people to reject the
agent reporter these Katan games always
get political
right here oh my God you guys would
never guess what I voted before not in a
Millions
don't you need a person I mean don't you
need a settlement
he was apparently
the number is
11. oh
shocking oh God
except for red
yeah and me I didn't oh no I just
couldn't shoot okay
okay so you need two roads to build a
settlement exactly okay um I I rolled a
fort and I first and they have to be
like two things away okay no no okay
three that's a good thing to ask it's
nice
okay I'm gonna build a road
right now
like two points seven oh seven count
them two three
like this
Dylan I love how you fixed by Road
smoker in the chat that's a good that's
a good username I like that you got two
times
unemployed
that's
that's his dating profile
it's just like two large voting blocks
unemployment my old Debbie
four
I press one in the chat if you like
menthol cigarettes let's see what we
have
you keep that up you're gonna stay in
that chair
I saw an advertisement for plants do you
want to have a weight
away
or for a week
build your cities
what do you need for a week and I have
it oh for a week what about the wood
okay
I'll do that getting into the characters
[Music]
sir would you like a sheep for uh I
don't really need a sheep oh a wood for
an ore
uh sure or ask for more oh wait a second
hold on never mind just put something
together okay
he's there huh all right that is rude
yeah
it's a competition so yeah all right hey
I don't know I got into it it's on the
drive home mate
I'm thinking it too
all right I'm gonna build uh Asylum whoa
because I have cash now holy [ __ ] you
sure 1-800
a settlement cash now damn everyone's at
three now right I'm at the hood y'all
one two three one two three oh right on
the beach
there you go oh thank you so much who
else do you think he's playing so
there's a Japan right now in the world
[Music]
four okay
four and we're not gonna forget to uh
uh before you give me a wood
thank you so much
the wood
who's this I don't know he's having some
people play Super Smash Brothers with
them oh boy pathetic inviting people
over to play games
do you think they would bet me a
thousand dollars to play me Super Smash
Brothers
you can tell people to their faces like
I have won tournaments
okay I wasted like half of my life doing
this yeah I'll still tell you I play
with uh Andres for two and a half hours
he didn't take a single life off me and
he was like this isn't Fun wow I'm gonna
use my job
[Music]
fair against each other I would destroy
everything I would say Zelda if you
could beat me in Smash I would already
know you because I was that big of the
tournament scene like
I would know your name I would know your
gamer tag sometimes we work in the
shadows yeah let's go there's no way I
feel bad say it you know me I'm not
confident about anything so the fact
that I have a like even a bit of
confidence about this should speed
volumes do you think if we both started
with three lives I could get one light
up life off of you
I'm gonna say Zelda yeah
great and that's a good answer
uh and ultimately foreign
[Music]
unemployed smoker says he can destroy
anyone in a smoke off
we just chain smoke cigarettes and don't
want to be puked that rules another
look at him blushing
[Laughter]
it was me I had one of the tracks
this should be the first one
there's not a second good thing
God damn it it's so crazy a girl for the
name dude and then hold on I might want
to play you got a 10 yeah
[Music]
I have wood
I have wood sir that's a [ __ ] Chopper
dude
damn now I don't need it yeah
I didn't like that fan when I stepped it
that's what I get I deserve that
it don't stand up too fast does anybody
need any wood or sheep what are sheep
here you throw a wood in a sheep and
I'll do it
you got two [ __ ] I got one over okay
that's fair
the guy plays Mark in what game if it's
not melee then Marth sucks not a hard
debater here
see here
anybody else have or I'll not imagine
anybody here or
you're talking ultimate
ultimate Man ultimate Super Smash yeah I
think I can do any of them I can go
randomly
n64. N64 is maybe your best chance but I
am so I still have a major one six
okay there it is have you ever seen me
becoming a single thing in my entire
life
brick for wood oh you're all the six yes
oh six sheeps
cheese
need sheep
[Laughter]
need wood when does the Aphex Twin start
playing what does Aphex twins
it was brick for what
uh or um eat
what do you have do you have a wedding
I don't have a sheep I don't know to
share what about this
um mystery you have wheat
yes fabric I don't have
brick okay can you give me a window we
all did it okay wait just because just
because we're new friends wood and the
wheat
allies over here okay
oh [ __ ]
okay so I'm gonna go where that ship is
oh
it's yours
what happens with this helper do you
need anything specific for a city oh so
what it is is any three can be turned
into anything so three of anything could
be one card okay
I mean besides having those things I
think Han said something where I was
like you need to have at least two oh
what are the where was on Brown roads to
go to a setup it's like this would be
fine if a settlement there I don't think
so because that one is there no
what do you need to build a city yeah it
used to be two away yeah the city is two
weeks whereas orange can like totally
build like oh you better build it on top
of your house so it replaces a house
yeah okay Alyssa what I'm stealing from
you oh
so City couldn't be here why
it could you have to build a house first
though oh you do yeah turn a house into
a city sort of same concept as Monopoly
okay so then I could put this I could
put a city right here yeah okay it's
cool I have rolled an 11. an 11. oh 11.
dance
all right I'm not really falling but I'm
I like Blues chances of winning who's
blue
Hans what do you need oh you just paid I
don't know why I just feel like you're
gonna come from behind right now
it's his favorite position Hans you got
any ore
from behind all right you know me so
well it's crazy
I got the Lord on my side let's go oh
the fans off what happened I was like
it's a [ __ ] machete look there's
nothing or a helicopter
who makes things like Texas Chainsaw
Vibes for sure
so does that come again sheep they need
shape okay go ahead
thank you Jesus
[Music]
what
does anyone have wheat
something
okay I'll do a wooden uh or okay like
that yeah sure cool
all right
I do I've got wheat I've got sheep I've
got
all I need is an ore yeah it can be
mirrored
it would just make everything confusing
I'll do a wheat for a while the fours
would be backwards I could do that okay
cool I know someone's in here is like
I'm sure
he's got all these rocks don't trade
with him I think that's wrong
that's Hans being like okay
racist
um you and Hans are tied with four and
and Dylan and then um
three-way tie I think a list is gonna
win I think she's sneaking I think so
too
Alyssa yeah she's like too polite for
they're not to be something going on
that's a very cool picture bro do you
have on your wall
thanks five
next where is the other five
there it is oh Brown picked up four
cards what she's the least picked up two
hopefully
I'm gonna go the road for the longest
road
oh
now he's in the lead
thank you
oh wait we don't have a hologram do you
have a Holograms that's all you get all
right this guy Fresco is pretty excited
right now like outside all capitals I'm
gonna purchase a development card
oh and then I will respectfully language
my turn
Adam
what are your thoughts
you ask about Kanye West one more time
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um Dylan's been going through them
go through what course that's why we
don't have any on our side
trading them okay Kanye gonna use my
night
yay
[Laughter]
you're red uh do you have a wood don't
don't tell it or wait no fan them out
and then I just pick one yeah
[ __ ] marry kill Aaron Carter Nick Carter
Vince Carter Bad Pig
yeah
actually here we go young boy it was
part of the game of strategy
all right okay and
Raptors Toronto Raptors Vince Carter
did you guys hear the question okay
that's not how it works
[Laughter]
you just couldn't stop thinking about
Nick Carter I would [ __ ] Marion kill
like sex
six little sheep that's a lifetime movie
I would like can I buy two things at the
same time yes it's sick
I will be poisonous
point you sing a road don't have to tell
everyone I think like his husband dies
and he's you know he's feeling like out
of sorts and then he just meets strange
man he like moves
so Robin Williams type figure I think
like
um yeah I think I would my setting would
be still in Plain and Tall I go from The
Busy City guys yeah I'm too busy with
business
and then switching out a city for this
one good job man I want to remake the
movie the lake house with Keanu Reeves
would you play Keanu Reeves because that
was the movie where he would put letters
in his mailbox and he would try to he's
trying to [ __ ] this woman that was in a
whole different dimension every yeah
imagine like being so desperate for
[ __ ] to try to focus reality
so insanely
let's see
unemployed smoker says fussy is bossy
that's what this is busy
so if I put it there can I build a road
even if it's I mean you can't go
anywhere okay you can build the road but
you can you can't go anywhere you
couldn't find your manager communicate
what's going on if you want the longest
road
if you don't know how to play Katan I
don't know what to tell you another road
here okay cool
thank you
ten
God damn wow Dylan is picking up a lot
of cars no I'm not look at that he has
got a whole duck over here
I'm gonna get seven
yeah
Kyle's Corey over here dude two sheep
for a brick
hey I heard you eat a stone huh well I
got them all
oh you guys want Stones huh who are you
[ __ ] Harry Potter yeah
[Laughter]
yeah maybe yeah
everything has a price doesn't it
move your [ __ ] like that I only put it
down for it should say that to people
you've been watching
I'm sorry I didn't see the before part I
apologize what a great show anyone wants
sheep uh for what bronze you have five
yeah
no okay so I'm gonna think about
everybody
let's see how many points he has after
this yeah
halfway there
kill Berry [ __ ] Stone wheat or ore yes
foreign
okay I told you
beer boy get me a beer you want a cider
they're delicious they're delicious
I might be able to get your sponsorship
I feel like it's funny comedians like
NASCAR drivers should cover themselves
and advertise them something awesome
are you stealing from Bill Hicks
or uh George Carlin
who's that
I think of politicians does anyone have
any sheep yeah uh for what I have ore
o
he's winning I'll take two
ornaments
stop helping him
anyone have any bricks or anything else
not a sheep salesman
she took my business
the capitalist elite why would you
assist him you think
I'm not assisting you without assisting
myself that's true no let's keep talking
look how many cards he has he's already
at Five Points he has that many cars he
has six or seven
yeah
everybody in the chat this is the part
of the game where Han starts to get
upset that he thinks he might not work
upstairs
this is
the part of the stream where Paul says
nonsense over and over again
sorry
I'll say it before on my next turn
and then I'm also going to use this
night card we're playing Seven Minutes
in Heaven that's the game it's just what
you get for bad mouth I'll take that
price
same thing you little dick oh you
sheeped me back
sheep
let me don't listen to Paul let me text
your pay all right oh you're in that
chair for a reason oh well
eleven so
11.
[Music]
what am I doing does anyone have any
bread
no no okay not for Traders there you go
I've got some sheets
[ __ ] the 10s
okay all right ten I can ground I got
blocked
um I'm going to buy it
it's a card
no
that looks [ __ ] up now
yeah it's wrong it's flat there's just a
lot you guys are really bumping into
each other now
you don't know anything about it
contained it's the old age debate yeah
how do you pronounce it actually I'm
gonna send my mom a video yeah
okay
hi I mean the whole thing is that was
the most unnatural thing I've ever done
creating the whole thing is
Taylor Swift's gonna go behind it
anyways they won't even hear that okay
good I actually I acted natural
no my mom really oh that's a good idea
to pinch a t-shirt like that it's gonna
do that too
um
yeah that's pretty good you can put it
under your shirt on stage yeah it has oh
wow and they have these little stickies
stick one right here goes under your
shirt and then when you're filming it's
great how do I get here is this here I
mean we wanted to you could have moved
that road to those other places and then
build there technically
Dylan I get really good audio but I just
shut my eyes off my ass
no I wish I did I
I what do you like sexually uh
sorry I'm interrupting Dennis he just
wants to joke around the whole time you
want to finish
I'm good you sure you don't want to
finish right now
I feel like Hans is finished in this set
of container
okay you got
you got along this road now me yeah I do
really I shouldn't say four but yeah but
like he already has the cards so like
four you can always it's always on go
okay
he said I did oh yeah yeah
don't respectfully really push anything
somebody said this table looks like a
reboot of community which is pretty fun
no they said I haven't seen this episode
of community before that's pretty good
that's a great job hey a DM you can
write for me okay
I'm on the Eliza Schlesinger tip I'll
just suck your dick I don't have
anything to cancel then again I don't
have anything for them looking for Brick
yes
of course
um
eight
so root
another rocks
it does
we have liquidation wooden sheep
the like the fake politicians yeah
put it in sheep does anyone have a
um a rock yeah but what are you gonna
what are you gonna give me what do you
got oh wait you have two weights no
you're one way yeah
I can't do that
sorry you need wood
do you need wood
um
do you have a brick yes okay I'll do
that okay the elite helping me
[Laughter]
there you go
we both have so much
so this game is basically just Monopoly
a development card pretty much sure yeah
it is
oh okay
okay you guys remember the Dane Cook
Monopoly joke it's a good joke
YouTube it
was it Louie's first who wants sheep
as if who wants wood I'll take a wood
for Rock
nah
the guy behind the camera looks like
Frank Zappa that's pretty cool
I think that
how about for wood for a sheep wood for
a sheep
that's uh I need a sheep oh I need a
weave can we do something do you have
Rock
yes
okay that works
concentrated a sheet for a rock
people want to know what's going on yeah
people keep complaining they don't know
what's going on all right
Oz is placing a that's a city it's a
city he built this city
will like put that song and it'll be
like uh oh my gosh
so I'm going tonight in the city
city of Holland's camp
[Music]
seven oh thank God
yeah cards oh that's Robert to a number
five
oh you're right
okay that's the worst possible thing
that could have just happened right now
okay
oh no I was talking to you if you got
more than more than seven okay just
barely made him yeah that's one thing
how many times
no
no he readjusts his chair is it just
blame it on something else oh my God
okay I'm gonna pass this one
I just really feel like fans shouldn't
be seven another seven
really does listen
rubber is being moved again
um
your reputation after you were caught
masturbating in the sink that's right
either door here nor there okay but who
doesn't do that
it's Blended
I um forthright give up
um
relinquishing it's like the Baton in the
Olympics
but Dylan has so many development cards
he's running out of the real catch-22.
I that's how you know you're in a
democracy is about the peaceful transfer
of power
actually could you move from Kareem to
the nine in the middle the Koreans yes
they say democracy is more about power
than sex no no
okay we've done that thank you so much
and then who are you going to steal from
um I'm wondering if anybody has some
[ __ ] for some
[ __ ] but you you get to steal one when
you put it yeah oh yeah from oh oh
[ __ ] for [ __ ] over there
[Laughter]
um
Dane your rib yeah
over here
good choice
that was a good one what was it like
growing up in New Jersey
yeah
me too oh really I'm from like North
Church
I'm from New Brunswick yeah I'm from
West Orange
I listened to a rappers from West Orange
and it always says West Orange so that's
why I know it all right thanks for
contributing
you still gotta take your card I used to
for Essex County America's office
I used to work for Wegmans
that's fine in New Jersey okay moving on
Wegmans is that the luggage
I
don't think anything about that
I don't know Peg man somebody's gonna be
like this
serious [ __ ] [ __ ] I need some
wood no it has it I need some hot
do you have a for wheat
for wheat
it should say commentated by Paul I said
his name one meat for one wood yes
yeah thank you
oh someone called it a boy bun not a man
bun
um and then is that my mom she up right
now boys
settlement so what do you guys think
about the whole uh you know Red Wave in
this election uh like the country went
red
yeah
should it yeah
you don't have to narrate your turn
I think it always just goes like
whatever
settlement like right here just because
back and forth
you can build it right here
does it or no I mean generally yeah so
like because Biden's in office now it's
like everyone's more red than Trump is
in office someone was yeah because the
answer is always in the middle well yeah
yeah like between Nazis and not Nazis
yeah World War II the answer was half
Nazis
I love Dane's look because he can go
Nazi or like left intellectual he really
can do either one he's a shape-shifter
yeah
lizard
Blizzard Man
all right my turn cool okay what do you
feel better I think that's a good thing
with a Democratic president if you're
trying to find the middle I would rather
have a communist president Like Bernie
Sanders oh I loved Bernie but they don't
let us have nice tattoos exactly two
words
the for the 2016 election the
Republicans went full crazy and elected
their craziest guy we should encountered
be like oh this is our chance instead we
pussy-footed put up like a yeah
scarecrow
hold on let me uh does anybody want wood
no for what okay that was the trade or
or
I need brick I also have sheep
all right
good cell how many volumes do you have
on your voice
you want me to be quieter no I'm just
curious I can get pretty loud I can get
pretty quiet
I've got some Bernie love in the chat
Bernie love yeah
I feel like I saw it like I said Bernie
more like attorney love does anyone have
a a rock yeah what do you have oh do you
need wood or break careful I need wood
put this one uh me I'm watching you
don't watch me
Sarah don't watch me getting up to
dubious things I mean dude
what do you need uh what rolling up a
blunt in honor of these seven folks and
you 14 individuals watching tonight
bless y'all thank you unemployed smoker
maybe put down the weed and apply to a
couple of jobs maybe he's smoking
cigarettes perhaps retail that's usually
entry levels doesn't even have
does anyone have I get it though dude
no
okay okay I'm gonna do something
um do it okay I'm gonna do something do
it [ __ ] who knows what might happen
have you seen the naked for you can I do
something might happen
if it does who cares oh and Evan Nelson
about to smoke a joint a lot of weed
smokers in the chat here I'm gonna do
that
you can never guess is
six word for two rocks because I have
the port and
yeah someone says
she's almost like Chris Catan okay
that's pretty good oh the European yeah
so I pick up this look at Alyssa right
now who invited Hermione Granger and I'm
gonna put down my Cleopatra she makes
all decisions I'm gonna do a settlement
are you Ron Weasley then over here okay
okay
I don't think you're understanding
I don't think you understand Harry
Potter
yeah one of us is mistaken about it what
are you uh Julius Caesar or
um
yes
Julius Caesar I'm very familiar hero
honey mustard
wood
oh there's the one I'll take one swallow
for rock yeah yeah
[Laughter]
what about
wait for Rock
wheat
who wants sheep for rock rock rock rock
I need Rock what about two Woods I feel
like I'm the only one with Prague yeah
it's not happening I don't trust you yes
unemployed smoker got a job today
he starts training on Thursdays
the Pentagon definitely at the deli
section of the Wegmans
sheep language
sheep for wheat yeah I love it how many
selling weed is not a job dude sure
thanks yeah
he's in the lead oh no not really yeah
not really he is he's this is what Hans
always does he always diverts it to a
common enemy yeah
yeah you're gonna go into politics
it's the bankers yeah exactly and then
all the while look he's gonna win who's
up to look at how many cars
I'm gonna use one card to give you a
beer hall push if you wanted to I really
think
hands
what
you have three trees
and then I get the largest army car hold
on
[Music]
Sir Dylan
you gotta jump at Microsoft what the
[ __ ] wow that is good plot twist good
for you you're gonna have a smaller dick
by the end of it
continue to be does anyone have a wheat
do you know that working in a war no you
know working in an office job lowers
your testosterone and reduces your
testicle size right yeah anyone who got
a week how do they test that
if I measuring just keep coming I know
what was the process just like every
couple months like all right wheatwood
bricks
yeah just call me Jim helper dude
wait would brick I wouldn't you know
that that's kind of embarrassing okay
too late now
don't trade with him he's about to win
no I'm not I believe you honor politics
I'm just saying I can't believe it
because I'm such a [ __ ] loser
I don't does anyone have a wheat a a
brick or a wood no wood don't trade I'm
just letting them know what I have I'm
like no
don't let him fool you Hans is in the
lead but then you'll be in the lead
Dylan yeah
wait a second that doesn't help me
what would help you Dylan is with the
Churchill and Hans is Muslim Rick would
help me I'm good sorry so what do you
need bro I'm about to lay down something
you guys
it's gonna be like the same way
completely cracked
as good as the Beatles I don't know how
to do anything we should hang out listen
to Beatles
I don't know enough of the Beatles so I
feel like you could really give me
anything
no he doesn't
by eight points is he really yeah how
many army guys do you have seven that is
when I like to be honorably discharged
and just
commit to town Suits now all right
she's winning
he put it down he's got eight minutes
how many of you have eight if you
haven't moved
let's see if it works out for him
um
well that's a bummer all right you don't
have to have a good job your job is not
the measure of your worth the worst
people have the best jobs and the best
people are the worst jobs
Hans came from bradlock
s you don't have to have a job if you
have a girlfriend that sells pictures
literally in my bag
s
yo it's gonna be close yeah
but you still feel like you're being
overtake I'm the closest
second three wow that's nice
she's great at uh colonizing wait if I
have that little house on that brick do
I get a brick or no what number that's
three nothing
we just roll the three now
yeah you got this yeah yeah yeah okay
call nice D's
yes
[Music]
you gotta pray to the fan gods
[Music]
but
just kidding I'm actually what color are
you I am orange
brown I didn't think so I don't know
much about the game but I I had a
feeling you weren't over because I see a
lot of only one story buildings and
oranges five
five good job Kareem I would say the
lack of strategy is running this game
you blocked a guy with six points and
not the guy with eight points real smart
strategy I don't know if that's a big at
me or not you're getting sunned right
now does anyone have a rock I'm confused
yeah it's okay it's okay I would like a
brick who has a brick I'll give anything
okay do you have a sheep or I have a
sheep you have a do you have a rock no
Westborough
for what I too
foreign
got Dane cooked we got Mr menage
the top 10. we have Bill Sullivan yeah
I'm sorry for the boom okay
are you gonna win this game okay
okay you don't know you'll never know
okay
Maybe
do they even have a
Rock
you are aren't you yeah for a break No I
gave the book away
all right I'm gonna do three uh I rolled
to ten I believe
um
pick up a freaking ride I think it was
miscommunication and can I have a uh
mathematics I'm also colorblind which
I'm totally not making this up right now
but I thought that was purple so that's
on me well Dylan is a purple
somebody asked what's everyone's choice
of caffeine
yes
orange okay I like uh methamphetamine
huh I was gonna say iced cappuccino
I would say sativa I need a seven
you're just joining us welcome to Dad
fan Settlers of Japan stream no nine
yeah
one two three
is turning things around right now
I can see it on Dylan's face he's
questioning it
I'm questioning I'm questioning how I'm
gonna celebrate
that's the winners 11.
everybody going to DraftKings you can
bet
I'm going to use your plenty Jesus
Christ
I don't know what I'm gonna get yet
I'm gonna get something dude just buy a
city
yeah
um
yeah I don't I don't even really need to
use it I was just flexing so
bada bang turn that into a city
and then I got a victory Point wow who
could have produced right now everyone
who could have predict hold on the side
of me the process that predicted that
did you win yes you won sorry everyone
good job guys
we're having fun okay how did you just
win okay so I got four five six seven
and then I have the largest army which
is two points eight nine and then a
development a victory Point what's the
largest army again it's how many if you
a few nights
gotcha oh three yeah and then roads it
starts okay and then you keep on
building I'm sorry okay but you would
have hypothetically needed four to beat
my three because I already put it out
yes
there's no shame though
still looks like he's in confusion on
this defeat
it's a tough one
you guys really let me down I mean we
saw that coming it's an upset
I told you and but who did he put the
robber on whose ball was that he did he
did the right thing yeah
Kareem you played yourself yeah it feels
great honestly
it honestly
it wouldn't have mattered I have so many
cards
so even if he would have gotten and
taken one of my cards I saw it and then
she would have rolled something
different and he would have rolled to
the difference
yeah
he had like 40 of them at one point he's
just having fun like I appreciate it
everyone in America watching this
appreciates you too that's still until a
game
but think down he's Pol Pot well we
still have plenty more games so we'll
still be here
tell your friends are we are we wrapping
it or are we doing this once more since
everyone knows the rules now anyone want
to say hi again who wants to play again
or who doesn't who wants to sit it out
who wants to sit it in and play another
game
interesting make up your minds and let
us know the options are twofold yeah
what do I do can I put a nicotine pouch
in my gum how do you do it I've never
done it do it my these ones are really
strong you guys want to steal some weed
and come back okay yeah sure you just
what do I do you just put it in your
upper gum this would be good radio it's
like uh it's like the same concept as
chewing tobacco but it's contained and
you don't need to can I put like the
left side it's just nicotine that
absorbs into your gums like here you
don't even see it one of those bro I'm
doing it don't do it no okay chat look
at me look at me disregarding my
girlfriend yeah
can we take a quick recess
please it feels good I've also got a
work meetings in business display oh it
feels good
night okay
this is the expansion right now is that
why yeah I guess it wasn't really an ass
live sorry
I turned this one off
this one's on you right Hans yeah okay
put it over there
these are good to wear your viewers hang
out with friends because they ever try
to lie to you you can be like really
because I've
recorded all of our conversations that's
it yeah yeah it's 4K team right here
yeah
perfect
development cards here
those are good for you
not that I need to be on camera but the
camera is not on me
so what do you guys think about
Kanye
what was the question can you repeat
that
what do you guys think about things
Thanksgiving yeah
where do you guys see yourself in five
years
um
I don't know
maybe Burger King or something hopefully
doing what I'm doing but better I'm not
doing great right now but
I think that's because I just jumped
into things
but at the end of the day is that life
just about like living the life but not
really about success that's true I guess
that's what I'm saying is like that's
why that's why people who are successful
it was very true
I feel like I am doing doing that
poverty is debilitatingly horrible it
really is which we've experienced and
then you're like oh I don't want that
yeah
I don't think it's that bad
I think I was happy when I was broke
honestly
because you know you're grateful for
[ __ ] once you start getting stuff you're
like yeah
oh wow
okay so yeah
you schedule these people to go around
but I did it like pre-cut pregnancy so
what did you think about masks mask
mandates yeah
it's only what everyone's been talking
about the last two years
well let's talk about something fresh
and new yeah
well you talked about people like
swinging back and forth I think it's
because people statistically aren't
happy so they always have to we'll never
like and then change them right like
we're very like
decisive at least not you know what I
mean yeah
it seems like since we're so uh divisive
it seems like people are more stubborn
politically I don't know
there's no guess there's no discourse
anymore
I could talk about these things
I'm actually looking for some side
tables for my new place I just moved in
you're married right you're married no
I'm not married oh okay I'm married to
the game yeah you know that damn game
you know what I'm saying I know exactly
what you're married like
Hans when do you think uh
would you get into a relationship what's
the last relationship you had I'm
currently in a relationship oh oh nice
congrats
how's it going or it's been a while I
don't know
uh
in between a long and a short
it's four months
yeah really yeah damn it yeah she's mad
at me because I didn't call her tonight
is busy playing content yeah yeah my
watch tonight
yeah there you go that's the uh she's
not very tech savvy
YouTube
it's just another thing unless it pops
up on our beach
you sound like
so when did she ask you out
the one conversation Hans is
uncomfortable why Wow
you don't want to talk about your lover
yeah I'll talk about
oh it's okay
I just got out of my relationship with
like a while like a week ago
single again
we're listening
no yeah it had been a while and
uh yeah now I'm single so I haven't
really
gotten to mingle
I haven't been to England no I've been
straight I've been cleaning my room for
the past five days
that's fun yeah there's no pressure yeah
well I just I really I really wanted to
get my wife it back in order and I felt
for the first time in a long time I've
had time for only myself so I like deep
cleaned the room I'm talking like closet
shelves inside closet I love it yeah and
uh that feels really good anywhere
totally
yeah
but I know and then it's like my desk
you know and then I just had all those
like clothes and the like clothes and
suitcases and closets I cleaned all of
it I went to Ikea I got new like
organizers and I just
got me a nice lamp
you know that sounds good not to brag
but uh it's only got a nice lamp good to
take care of yourself and be like I'm
just gonna take care of me now no it
really does feel good I know that
sounded so sarcastic but it does feel
good
think about the money you'll save being
single around holidays
oh yeah that's a benefit
all that cash
No Love
they were a really good person yeah it
feels nice
gonna be good I feel like this one's
gonna be a tight one it's better to have
loved and lost than to never have loved
at all absolutely amen
yeah let's roll for it
let's start her off
six
I think relationships are great
hey
we got rid of the women
too has it been a while since you've had
been in a relationship no not really I
was dating this one girl for like two
months and this other girl for two
months
all right
I can grow that's down
11. yeah just be really good at getting
like a little
kidding late
there you go see you star this is lap
okay did it make sense
so I just I um
when I'm starting I put these down now
okay cool Hans how do we get a sponsor
for this to give us like a drink for us
to drink how many beers the way we do it
is by not focusing on it and creating a
great broadcast yeah we're just having a
good conversation and like just being
yourself
cool so beautiful
as possible which direction I mean are
you always playing a character do you
know who you are well I think
Shakespeare said it like we're all
actors on the world's stage so isn't
your perception of reality gonna
influence like
your natural organic being
exactly I have to get sponsored by a
beverage company
foreign
have a good time
I don't have to like record everything
and make it weird not like monster
no that's fine if you want to do that
he's a whole board thing just goes right
next to him
so what do you guys think about sponsors
like is that really the way to go or
should we have a more organic natural
approach
for making money off podcast what do you
mean we're doing podcasts longevity
what are other ways to kind of what are
other ways to make money I like
crowdsourcing a lot I like the idea of
that like
having paywalls for extra content
but there should always be
free at at the start of it
um
I don't know how much sponsors would
like pay out so I have no idea of what
that world was like
I mean I feel like if that's what you're
getting into it for then it's the wrong
kind of mentality in my opinion right
but that's what you asked
so would you do it or not
what I do what have sponsors
um it depended if it would impact the
content
how it would impact the concept if they
were cool with whatever flies then yes
of course
well and but it also depends on what
they do like is it just one of these ad
reads at the beginning or middle or end
of an episode yeah there's a lot of
specifics
of what you would accept and not accept
well I like that we have a middle
eastern person here to make money in
business out of things
I am I'm from the Middle East from New
Jersey
whoever your parents are from
wherever Palestine they are to go
straight off the carpet from there are
they actually obviously right yeah wow
my mom is that foreign
a New Jersey
really
that's not the Middle East
Hans since you asked what do you think
about sponsors pay walls Etc I don't
think they're necessary it'd be nice
but uh then where is the money coming
from
um from other things like the shows
and working
but uh yeah I don't know
do you think you could just use it to
promote your other stuff instead
the podcast yeah like using the podcast
not focused on making money but to then
promote your shows like kind of what
you're saying or yeah to make money
otherwise and settle
different ways but yeah I mean I think
thinking about business is fun I love
business
sometimes well there's ways to be
creative in it in comedy because like
you've got someone like Louie who I mean
got famous before
the podcast got huge yeah and now he's
just got his sight but then I don't know
it's just an interesting challenge
yeah
and that's where you talk about the
crowdsource right like finding people
who actually want to like hear your [ __ ]
like I'm on his email list too like
right I like to get emails I love his
emails he like personalize it yeah he
makes them funny so I read his voice to
them yeah all right I'll go pet my dog
now and die because I said last sentence
I love that [ __ ] it's great he's like
hey if you're reading this
is that that's so good seeing my Creek
dude did you get to see him like he's
here uh I was on the other side of the
curtain at the creek listening
yeah
like what he actually uses it and then
there's a point like where he literally
like forgot a joke and he's just sitting
there for like
15 seconds which that's a long time in
comedy yeah trying to think of his joke
like he's performing I think student
Austin again at like one of the bigger
theaters in January oh no [ __ ] yeah
that's cool
it's a goat
what do you think about Mitch Hedberg
hello
I thought he was amazing
everyone's like you can't do short jokes
and do an hour and people will get bored
but they just haven't seen someone do it
well like Mitch Hedberg
yeah maybe he's
I don't know he's probably one of the
best though at that but how do you do
that many one-liners for an hour
not get mixed up like did I say this one
already did I not like
yeah I just I don't know
if it's only 10 to 15 seconds
I think my favorite is him
talking about how long it takes to make
a baked potato
and that even if he's not in the mood
for the baked potatoes he'll make it
because maybe like when it's done he'll
want the baked potato
all right he's talking about frozen
bananas
yeah baked potatoes no it's a frozen
banana well he also has one I swear
that's about a baby yeah I don't think
it's that one
do you what do you guys think about
because you bring up Mitch Hedberg like
jokes and stuff is uh the difference
between someone who does jokes and
someone who does like longer bits
uh ego self-obsession
what do you mean they're like I just
people just need to hear my story okay
well what if it's hilar I I mean I would
say like someone like Phil Burr has like
longer bits as opposed to like
you know like
he's trying to get a point across it's
not just about him like
you know some people like Gerard
Carmichael or like
he's a good example yeah it's just like
oh look I'm the one talking that feels
so strongly
should be able to think for you
is that the vibe you get
yeah I mean it's just like they're not
offering much besides their Essence like
this is who I am like they're not
offering ideas and arguments and
you know a little
cool little things it's just more about
them and just the fact that they're up
there and like like rap
there is something that is an
interesting point of like
like did you watch rathaniel
no it was it was very that yeah
um I got gay yeah but not it was it was
more like that but it wasn't
so many jokes and people were like oh
it's so like profound but it's like I
didn't if I wanted something profound
like don't make a comedy space yeah
I I expect there to be a lot of laughter
and yeah if you're gonna be the guy that
makes a point you also have to bring
laughter to it yeah like I thought his
eight eight was a good mix of he was
like making points but they were it was
funny
or like his even his first one at the
store in the OR
but rathaniel I thought was kind of a
jerk off
yeah yeah
I mean that's what a lot of people like
nowadays they want like cotton candy
comedy just like a look
not the intellectual part they can bite
down into but just like that's what I
found in going in New York or maybe
there was some pocket I found like
intellectualism
is trying to make a is trying to make it
smart
which I think is done
in comedy
it's it's not comedic to be like yeah
smarter than you right and but some
people love that and I have no idea why
yeah I don't understand that I I
actually made some comedy beefs there
with some of these types who's whose
turn is naked
but they didn't pick up your second so
there's some people no I put this in
that group that looks down
jokes and I think that's stupid yeah
yeah or that it's not smart enough but
it doesn't have to be smart but it can't
be [ __ ] no I mean like in the
structure of the material that's where
the smart comes out but about dumb [ __ ]
like you can make an amazing [ __ ] joke
that's it's like impressive
how much structure and thought went into
a [ __ ] joke and it's still a dumb idea
yeah
but I mean there are political comedians
that are really funny like Bill Hicks or
like George Carlin sure
if it's natural to you to talk about
that if it's not forced
and I think it's like you have some
political stuff right yeah yeah
but I wouldn't
like if you're talking about Hans Kim I
wouldn't say
you wouldn't describe yourself that way
yeah three very political which is a lot
of people don't like that
but yeah I mean it's like uh you can
talk about like bigger things and like
people will want to hear like if you're
purposely limiting yourself
but if that's what you naturally think
about
it's like
is there any comedy review as lesser
uh I like crowd work Comics I like Road
Comics that can kill
what was that I don't know like bad
comedy foreign
[Laughter]
be mad at some because they don't think
you're sure
like I I do but I am
no I I agree and well there's only
certain times that
I like the comic that can get out yell
at it but there is like a very clear
difference between someone who pulls it
off and someone who doesn't
you can feel it it's like you can
literally feel
oh yeah evens feel like the comedians
hate inside their heart
almost immediately when they start their
set five
of someone when you put that down no
idiot
that means
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Road
10 is serious man oh no we don't [ __ ]
around here probably yeah we don't
Pander to anyone too
we you know play Contagious
please
all right you're out HK 47.
7 nice yeah I am screening oh seven yeah
we Robbins I know
[Laughter]
he still got his revenge
I hope you find it I have a long memory
foreign
yeah yeah okay
how do I conservative comics
I mean Jordan I don't not like this
conservative comment but Jim Brewer is
doing a lot of conservative comedy
um what do you say that do you mean like
rally ass like what do you mean I don't
like self-centered Comics like Nathaniel
or the special but I also don't like uh
Like Comics that are like too right-wing
or like ooh so I have a trick question
then what do you think about Tim Dylan
then well that's the thing is depending
on who you ask because like I asked some
of my friends from like LA and New York
and they're like Tim Dylan's like a
right wing yeah I I know well that's
what they think uh I loved him doing
like
he's hilarious well he's like America is
[ __ ] up and horrible and awful but I'm
I love it and I'm gonna have a good time
right yeah it's just like there's a
playfulness in like the misery
yeah I like that is the Irish playground
in hell yeah
it's so weird that these days now
there's so many Comics who I wouldn't
think would be conservative comics and
then they get labeled as such just
because they said something you know
unpopular to the masses or whatever
and it really depends on who you ask
but that's that is like a strange thing
because
I don't know like even I don't know if
you guys got this but a lot of my
friends
when I moved here were like oh you're
gonna be conservative redneck and I was
like I'm it's like we live next to the
[ __ ] Google building I went to Panera
bread today and they think it's this
like
you know gun toting
well that's Austin there's a big
difference between like Austin and Texas
and yeah well they think they've they
view Austin as this like right wing
playground but it's like you I've met
some of the most liberal lefties of my
life here so it's it's a weird Paradox
it feels like a little island here
yeah yeah
where did where did you move from San
Diego oh okay oh are you from there yeah
oh I just moved from San Diego to here
oh cool we're there for like four years
oh nice speaking of war horn does anyone
have an ore I got a sheep and a wood
yeah do you do have you ever done any
sets in San Diego homes yeah I've done a
couple sets there yeah I mean like Texas
everyone thinks it's gonna be like
whatever but then it's like not that
sometimes
right yeah
I couldn't say anything
sometimes it's not what you think it is
a lot of times
all right back to the game nine nine all
right
yeah let's focus up [ __ ] yeah that's
what I needed
why why did James from
[Music]
this will be the next place
we're gonna
see her foreign
was telling me in New York they were
like Hans can't Hans Kim wants to open
my king here
[Laughter]
[ __ ] reps yeah it was nothing nobody
cared about me I didn't get booked on a
single show no one gives a [ __ ] my
calendar was empty wow
was that the place you were at last
um was New York yes before the pandemic
this was New York yeah what might be
here in New York
what was like your go-to Grizzly pear or
something like right in the Cave Creek
oh yeah that's yeah I lived right
outside of it two and a half minutes
really yeah they let you at one and a
half
no oh my God all packed with comedians
especially on a Friday or Saturday
because that was the only place solely
dedicated to open mic and comedy so you
were built for kill Tony it's just like
yeah
made for
it so if I if I do the thing on the the
car do I then have to like give it back
or can I just hold on to it are you
supposed to see you just uh not really
stupid here you only use it by your next
turn usually right so you just bought it
I just bought it okay yeah you can't use
it okay thank you all right
it's like if you bought a car and
they're like hey
you can't live with it right now you
gotta come back tomorrow
come back tomorrow
foreign
yeah I mean uh New York was a fun time
who said that who was uh I'd have to
I forget who it was if I think of the
name Elena can I give you a wood for a
wheat
uh yeah honestly because you just had so
nice like that yeah
what are you talking about dude we're
very prideful we trade
we trade like olive trees
by the Israelis
deep God
oh no I I I'd have to thank you
for facts I'm a citizen of the world
well it's funny I feel like people in
Europe know what's going on in the
Middle East in America but it makes
sense because look at the [ __ ] map
they're like next to it like do we know
what shit's going on around us like I
would hope so you know we don't we just
have ocean
Israel
yeah they're kind they're chill we're an
isthmus
oh god oh I use it the night at I should
have used this before
do you think um
since you almost won the last game
who's winning currently yeah he keeps
going uh
you're very anti-second place
you're very anti-stepping first place
you can give a [ __ ]
second place
I'm building a rug or a temple whatever
you want to call it
this way all right I'm done thanks there
you go I play my knight
yeah
remember when Paul said he's really good
at Smash Bros
Hans Revenge
Revenge is gonna blind you
eight
we did that for you
oh that was a good one
eight strategies
okay
six
months
got a little something something nice
did you use that development card are
you chilling on it with the victory
Point by the way you don't show us it's
just a point you had in your head
by the way price you told it out
is that what it is
like hey you got a point dude is that oh
then that's a night so you can imagine
when you move that thing and then you
can pick up from someone you move the
robber
you can use that if I want to use it you
use before or after yeah so you could
use it this term can I still hold on
because you guys tally these at the end
right am I crazy or no this is just to
kind of help yeah once you play it so
once you play it it counts and if you
get three of them then you get that okay
so I'm gonna
play it so I can move this one yeah all
right moving it over to this five back
to the five and I'm going to
steal from highs
well how many you got I mean you got a
little over there you already made it
looks like he has a city
he's got three points so part of his
cards are in the city so he has five
cards that no I got four
steal from his win he's got three points
he's got a city doubled up on his dots
he already decided
oh
no I'm never getting invited back all
right
um
all right I just got a little settlement
Boop wait no
I guess it happens
um
can I do a settlement here in the middle
no
but you could technically do it there if
you wanted to if there I guess
yeah sure
okay
five
days
I'm trapped again
nice let's go nice get some stones
for the bones
six
so what's the deal with uh
what was it
I was trying not to say it out loud so
you could ask you a question
go ahead I was trying not to say
anything but they couldn't see
so yeah I mean
we're Kanye
what's the deal with what
what is the deal with women oh seven
seven
they take half your [ __ ]
move that first would you say like
you're closer to a white person or a
black person
you know that's a great question Hans so
I was filling out a job application once
no seriously and uh next ethnicities
they'll literally have listed like what
you are and like my parents are from the
Middle East and it
went next to the word Caucasian so
technically people from Middle East are
Caucasian hashtag Jesus
um I thought yeah I've been white this
whole time
so which which way if you look at my
legs
which race correct yeah you can pass
which race do you think white people
think are the closest to them oh that's
a good question
um
[Music]
uh
wow he's evil
okay okay I apologize
that's harsh oh look how evil look what
he did over here too bastard well that's
scary that's for the ring
let's just have fun here
nine
896 yeah
I did that to protect Hans I couldn't
I know Andy's gotten to development
clubs I don't talk [ __ ] I'm not stealing
from Hans no more thanks good that's a
good choice all right HK okay you got
stolen from Once dude I'm an only child
I have no tolerance for anything against
me all right only childhood
then I guess I've got two enemies
you slightly
seven
let it fuel your decisions
like the kid that got bullied that
already knows he's gonna be the one who
has to give us lunch money so he just
gets it out yeah there you go no I'm
definitely not gonna win this one oh my
God
Hans could handle one win one win from
the kid
uh what if I don't want to steal from
you now
oh my God you do
it's like I didn't invite you all to set
this all up and put this online
I've never seen so many nights
I don't know what shape or
anyone watch sheep or Rock
sheep or rock yeah I'll try to do a
sheep for a sheep
whoa
[Music]
we wanted
next I love how Paul was talking so much
[ __ ] about Smash Bros lost and then left
to the first game first game
I saw his Spirit leave himself
one word yeah he was really mad I didn't
hear about it
his girlfriend was consoling him on the
couch
so it was very demasculating years ago
yeah I went well it was like yeah maybe
like I'm pretty good too he's like I
would have known you were like yeah like
that's how good I was
it was hilarious for how like how much
goes I believed him too talk [ __ ] you
lose the ore yeah it's a lesson in ore
you know I like Sarah that was four well
yes
you know we did see it event controller
so now you know
yeah it could very well be about I love
control with you oh yeah
I'm gonna make some moves
money moves yeah
um
you some now call me sheep Lord
Gaylord
oh oh it's John imagine naming your kid
Gaylord Hans wouldn't that be like send
him up for Success yes
10.
10. oh nice
that's what I need
who wants sheep
what's wood
I'm gonna buy a development card hey
Hans what do you think about comedy
animes
I think that
I'm a defense
but I have a lot of them do you yeah
three three
I don't I just don't get along with some
people and I don't think like
uh some people like abuse like how much
trust you have to have in them to like
get away with more [ __ ] and like what
people are a waste of energy I can't
imagine you being the antagonizer
are you that's good I I seem more like
you getting annoyed with people pushing
their boundaries yeah is that right okay
but then I might have big boundaries and
be like oh you're encroaching on my
territory when they're just being like a
golden retriever yeah which I hate but
that's like comedy you're gonna have a
little bit of a backbone
it is weird when you say something no
one like they don't hit back
yeah you know
who's who's a comedy enemy you don't
have to say like a name but what's your
first comedy enemy and this goes to
everybody First comedy anime and what do
they do
or when you just remember pretty vividly
oh you got longest road
you don't have that card
there it is that'd be like people can go
to show it and you were like
just like someone in comedy you beef
with and why
I don't know this is cool and San Diego
is in Mike wants that um American Comedy
Club pack show and I run this joke to
walk up to tell and the comic
that was like up said the job
strand being like Amazon sponsor or
something it was a really bad joke and
then this comic said the joke and I
wished him really bad things
so it was just like a familiar enough
joke that he had also thought of it yeah
which told me that was that was a shitty
joke sure
okay that's a good one anyone else
um
comedy enemies
um
I mean I just
I uh
I hate a lot of people yeah
I do too I shouldn't but I do who do you
like that once and why should we like
them
um
I like a lot of people too eight
I don't think I really have any common
enemies but I think sometimes I kind of
get my groove of like going into a lot
of open mics and then just not
socializing enough to where I feel like
there are like friend groups and people
are more social with each other that not
that I'm an enemy with them but I'm not
friendly so I think I probably you don't
you don't like the Hang as much oh I do
like the Hang but it's another sometimes
I just find myself I end up not doing
that I just go and do my doing Mike and
I get the [ __ ] out yeah so I could
probably be better at me being more
social
it's not that I'm an enemy with anybody
though okay I think it's good to protect
yourself a little bit you don't want to
open yourself up too much because really
you want to just have a good
uh comedy career it's not really about
other people it's like a individual
sport that you play with around other
people like golf huh yeah yeah
I would say like golf I like that that's
a good one
that's your point
yeah you just gotta find a good group of
people and just yeah protect yourself at
all costs yeah when you say protect
yourself though what do you mean by like
what am I protecting myself
from like those negative energies okay
bad thoughts yeah sexual vlogging
frustration that's uh
that's the thing I find myself trying to
protect myself from is people who uh
make it not fun
okay yeah
like
there's always they always find a way to
[ __ ] sneak in they do they're like
there's so many goddamn vultures in this
in comedy and there's so many
unfortunately yeah emotional vultures
who will just pick pick away in
conversation and I'm trying to get
better about not even entertaining like
if someone says some passive aggressive
[ __ ] just walk out of a circle or call
them out like [ __ ] you you because I
mean comedians are all so sensitive and
more like the guy that's like oh man
that guy really embarrassed me socially
yeah yeah yeah talking to each other
yeah you're just bumping into each other
all with our insecurities and
fragileness oh did you see Akash sing
get roasted on Reddit for posting a clip
no what was that he posted a clip where
this guy was just like Stone facing him
the entire show so he was like roasting
him
I get the Queen's dead I'm glad the
Queen's dead
and just like he's doing like some like
he was doing stand-up which some of it
was kind of hacky but I think he was
using it well and I think the guy was
being an [ __ ] but the internet's like
you should be allowed to be autistic and
sit in the front ride a comedy show and
just like not be vibing or
you know like they that's like Reddit
like they're all like losers and yeah
right right but like so I mean did was
the guy even autistic did they check up
did they check if the guy was autistic
British
it's just being just being into like in
his own head
so
whatever but yeah I hate that the the
people in the audience that are just
like what what else do you got yeah
because that's a Vibe and like you don't
have to bring that to a comedy show no
they bring their all their their
personal [ __ ] yeah yeah I cussed the
lady out I called her like a [ __ ] like
eight times
I played this last week and I was only
like the third comic up and she left
right after my son
I but I feel like there's some people
and this goes for men and women but
there's some people that just they they
don't get to hear that very often in
their lives and they need to hear it
more like she doesn't get challenged
yeah you know she was like uh you know
New York I literally had a show in New
York
where I said a joke and some lady stood
up and I called her account as well and
I think that happened more in New York
than like other places because you have
those what was that no no the girls who
are like they're like having a full
conversation right right next to the
stage they're not even in the bathroom
and then they can instantly make you the
villain
now yeah women am I right no there is
like uh
yeah no that [ __ ] is infuriating and
they need to hear it every once in a
while I swear like those people need to
hear it the most
yeah because they're not only [ __ ]
you over they're [ __ ] over the entire
show because you have to stop and
address it and then sometimes if like I
have a you know I gotta watch my anger a
lot so I'll like blow up on people and
then and then all of a sudden there's a
line where the crowd's like oh why'd you
go you know and then I'm [ __ ] and my
sets [ __ ] so their time is also [ __ ]
yeah they put those those people are so
selfish it's insane yeah why even go
no right you should be at a club go to a
club yeah yeah go dance an interactive
art form it's not like a play even in a
play right I shouldn't go to a play and
just be like
falling as yeah right
like you're creating a Vibe and yeah I
mean that's what everyone thinks
stand-up is it's just like you go well
no matter what the audience is you bring
them in you make them laugh but it's
like you only get a certain type of
comedy by the way
right and then you don't get a lot of
this other beautiful comedy
let me ask you this how much are you
reading a room now if your opener
doesn't do well are you gonna go up
acting like
like are you gonna change your [ __ ] up
because you think these people you know
what I mean like you know I would do
that would you do that do what like if I
used to love like when I'm about to go
up in the crowds not laughing I thought
I was like oh this is good you're gonna
have an actual challenge versus the
crowd laughing at everything you know
what I mean so I mean do you really need
to struggle and fight or can you take an
audience that is you know might be
uh
oh yeah like can you take an audience
that's laughing at everything and take
them where you want to go like do you
always have to like find yourself as a
counter puncher or do you have like the
direction and initiative to take the
audience instead of like just being led
by them true yeah yeah
talk with him hey does anyone have a
goddamn brick
no we got bricks
lives have been ruled
um
I'm gonna trade these in for a break
so it's back
yeah I uh I blew up on this lady
and where is this at this was at uh
monks Jazz Club
all right
and I've had I've had several of those
like when I was in New York I had a lot
of those like I would it was so
frustrating I was working on some like
newer stuff and I would start with a
premise
I like I have this premise where I start
the joke with uh I've been scaring women
and then all of a sudden this chick in
the back's like oh you think that's
funny
I know like well it isn't yet but that's
the premise
you know
you know I know it's like you're not
looking yeah yeah
but the standard shouldn't be that if I
am then it's all all okay yeah if I I
told her I was like rely on yeah if I
was if I was she would have loved me if
I was flamboyant and coming in with uh
Queer Eye For The Straight Guy she would
have loved me then and then I could have
said it but that shouldn't be the
standard and it is a scarf and a little
trilby hat
they're like like violence against women
unless unless it's with a lisp you know
I rolled a three well that's yeah well
that's the thing is that obviously like
what did she think did she think that I
was
that's where it ended that I am that I
just like scary one I don't even hear it
I don't want to hear another word they
don't want to hear any
hypothetical
you know they're just tired of your
brain and your mentality I know you
should just ask like you should be what
do you want me to say yeah like ask them
what would you prefer by saying that
right besides this joke I had written
let me tell you guys what would you like
me to say no dude it would be like if I
went if I if I read once upon a time and
I was like that's terrible yeah
yeah time yeah
yeah yeah I mean I feel like comedy you
should be able to make fun of like
anything right isn't that the rule
that's it nothing's off bounds
can't talk about the Jews that says
no bounds but yeah no it's it's really
uh ridiculous okay that people come to a
show where they're like I'm here to
listen to other people and then they're
like well I don't agree with that so I
can steal from anyone
I gotta split up my cards anyway first
okay yeah it's interesting that's what
happened to you too you know I mean like
specific like no it is mind-boggling but
then if I say I'm gay then they're
whatever about it
let's see how this now
it shouldn't be the standard for anybody
this game is moving along
oh damn
look at you bam yeah making some Quiet
Moves
four nights
yes we should play that game oh yeah you
got the largest army yeah fortnite I
love it when they switched the analog
thing on me that kind of [ __ ] yeah
like the up to go down I was like I'm
done here
um dyslexia when it comes to up and down
in left and right I think I don't know
if it's horizontal or vertical
yeah I think you're wrong I thought I'd
be too fast
11.
there we go if that works
I don't have [ __ ] [ __ ] who really
needs something I can relate to this
sorry
sorry
okay
okay pet peeves that other comedians do
and that could be uh stage or off stage
people who are low energy Comics that
are trying to do high energy comedy if
they think that's better
it's like you're a low energy comic like
just stick with that just do one-liners
you don't have to like
oh like putting it on like obviously not
who they are yeah yeah yeah for your
expectations right like
yeah don't try to be something you're
not don't try to be Jim Carrey don't be
something you feed yourself you can't be
is what you're saying that makes sense
nice it's just like their idea yeah of
what they think they should be is a lot
less interestingly who they actually are
hmm
nice
this is a it's gonna be an ongoing
battle
whoever whoever can [ __ ] break
here whoever can seize the opportunity
of seeing our game rivalry will win
we'll beat us both
possible right now
oh my God
Stephen sure
11. oh my Skeeter got me oh no oh
should we get this song yeah
11 11. nice
um I need wheat where's wheat I have
lots of things
well
choose two purples I have one stone
for one weed I also have sheep
all right give me a stone machine
for a week yeah
do you like Austin
that was back alleys
thesaurus
I don't like Austin I love it oh oh why
do you love it
would sir not so loud the so intense
heat in summer
the non-existent police force yeah the
police here are grumpy
means
I want to be killing people you're gonna
start doing QR codes
wait no no yeah
all right be crazy you don't even have
to be white to be a cop anymore like
they just they're hire anyone
oh look that's the mosquito get it
where's this all gone
uh downstairs
give me a pair of Chopsticks yeah a Zeke
is still going around I don't think so
right I remember that was a thing hey do
you have a Wii I got let me check my
friends I give you good price too very
good price does anyone have wheat no no
I don't give a good price
High School
anyone got an award
I gotta I'll put a sheep and a wood on
it for an ore I keep it away sorry okay
um
I'm Blue
and F4
last offer I will give a wood a sheep
and an ore for a week oh yeah no one has
that we don't have wheat
for what if a wheat I'll give uh
sheep or in a wood
that's three cards
and a North no I can't do two shades of
water but you're getting a wood a sheep
and an ore for a one week it's three one
uh yeah man okay
you convinced
all right
so why do you think Reddit was like so
against the Kosh Singh
because there's a bunch of people are
[ __ ] nerds I don't know
did this is just gonna let people go to
comedy shows and be like I don't have to
try and then everyone's gonna be like
dealing with that for the next six
months redditors there was a video
recently though where uh TJ Miller was
like messing around with the crowd and
there was one guy he started talking to
and the guy kind of answered him you
tell the guy was just a little off and
he just he made it funny of being like
I'm not gonna roast you you seem like
you like you have enough in your life or
like something like that and that was
also hilarious too of like
saying I'm not going to roast this
person for good reason because you tell
the audience was a little bit right when
the guy has said something he was just
like oh don't make fun of this guy he
handled it well that was a different I
don't know it was definitely the
opposite way to handle it which yeah it
was really funny in the same way
um I really liked that like crowd Work
video there yeah um
I think it's up to whatever you do
yeah I mean sometimes you don't want to
do crowd work on some type of person
yeah
and you can just be like okay now it's
gonna be a performance again yeah yeah I
like that too segwaying back into it is
wild
it's interesting to watch both because
as a new comic uh I'm trying to figure
out like what's the best move I'm like
and I think there is no best move it's
based off of like what it is in the
moment too so
head upstairs
who has long as far right now red yeah
he does Jane does with what seven two
four six seven right yeah what number
was that sorry seven
foreign
that's true they're in Asia
they're separated by the Himalayan
Mountains they're two culturally diverse
feet
collects of heat
yes three break
hey
strategy all right what am I doing oh
yeah
so
where's the sound effects guys
12. oh I haven't seen it 12.
ouch
red you got one
12. sorry about how many twelves
all right back forward
back up on the blue to make sure they're
really dead
um
that looks like an unfortunate seven can
we have a replay
it is tipped but
you guys is cool isn't it where it would
fall as a role for it
one two three yes four to six no okay
no you're gonna use one die though oh
[ __ ] just one oh yeah roll roll for the
world yeah so one through three is yeah
one for three
no it was not a sign so roll again
[Laughter]
it was a set was it a seven it was
tilted on the side that's what I'm
saying was it a seven I don't think it
counts yeah let's just do it over again
don't lie
the thing about life all right I would
like to take from Hans Camp I have four
two courses
yes sir
um
nine
I kind of want to be on pause but I want
to take one of those you know
Monopoly card
what do you roll
should I have rolled first no no no you
did it correct no oh he just bought it
did it wrong yeah yeah he did it wrong
no he he bought it last turn but he
played it before him now I still get
this point do I get to keep the point
it's not a point you need to take off
and wait for your role yeah
he made a mistake yeah right also if you
buy seven yourself yeah but you gotta
eat your weight yeah do you have any
weight I have none do you have any
weight I have no weight
I don't eat either all right cool
the rolls
four let's go
damn
yeah Hans I'm not the one to be worried
about this one
go to the sky
it's five to four to four to four
Danes winning
oh
Dylan's tied
um
Dane
what
don't speak to me that way
um
I will give you two ores for a brick
two walls full break so that you can
build a city
[Music]
um
let me think
yeah
cool
thank you sir yes
sorry there we go oh okay
[Laughter]
yeah
that joke was awful yeah that's what I
said hey you were like a zombie please
wasn't a joke terracing
laughs
hey how was London I'm sure everyone's
asked but it was amazing
was it cool London Town
London they're like Germany except they
speak English
did all the material trans uh Translate
a little bit
uh it was mostly the same for sure a
week for a sheep anyone
no
I would have done that I just couldn't
compute there you go I like the little
fox video it's a little fox in the city
yeah
three oh you're so quick with it you're
like I know
I want sheep
and three you're the three yeah
go ahead
foreign
I feel like British people are just like
really good at the English language
like better than Americans I agree I
went to uh like a comedy show yeah like
the more touristy one and the way they
presented jokes was way more elaborate
than
an English comedian never would based
off of like
their literal vocabulary I was just
yeah
but they don't have the emotional
Red Line there their emotions are just
really in the middle they never go Peak
which is bad because we can defeat them
in the war yeah
like you may be sarcastic I don't know
if there's people can be sarcastic
they think it's sarcastic they're good
at sarcasm rolling their eyes yes that's
what they want me to do they want me to
go to the parking
team station again
you can't do that [ __ ]
you gotta build the road oh yeah you're
watching he's a doctor oh yeah yeah
I love Ricky's race on that show oh my
God he's like I'm still going with it
say Your penis
there's a good dog to it
I listen to a podcast with great
information Russell Brand and it was
[ __ ] the creepy yeah spontaneous
right
yeah nine
did you have to pay for it
um I don't think so it might have been
on Spotify does anyone have a brick
nope
for what
um yeah
English people are really atheistic Like
Richard Dawkins is and he's from England
[ __ ] there's like really atheists like
they're not like anti-goblers yes but I
can only do one a week yeah
yeah they don't have their face value
they're not like I can't I believe it's
really terrible but I'll do a one-to-one
how is that gonna help me get to
they're like very in the middle and
let's be uh observant
um but yeah like
they're not like whoa
that's us that's America
I I like Australian humor a lot have you
guys ever seen the show danger five five
oh
damn there's still that robber there no
I'm not is it no what is it it's great
it's like set up it's a it was released
like five years ago but it's set up like
it's a
spy show of the 60s
and set up like it's a spy show in the
70s it's like a group that like goes
around the world fighting
uh
anyway the premise of the show is each
episode they try to catch Hitler but
Hitler gets away at the end of each
episode but jumping out of the window
and like they just like Nazi dinosaurs
and like it's so fun it's a great show
really funny humor oh okay and like the
the
I'm going to
the sound is all off
as long as friends
off it sounds hilarious yeah it's great
danger five
Australian show
did I lose my two points from that yeah
I think Australians are so cool because
they're well trafficked like they're
notorious for like traveling going on a
holiday
opposite the winter summer thing yeah
they get to just enjoy life honestly and
have cool accents
did you move it yeah oh yeah
do you guys like Jim Jeffries I feel
like I love Jim Jeffers yeah oh he's
like original HBO getting drunk Jim
Jefferies is like yeah some of the most
best comedy of just that
I love what he does like an English
American accent well I'm an American and
I have a gun like he he does it better
than some yeah six
that won't do
would you mind
help them out
three
foreign
sex
another six
and anyone want brick
yeah
how about foreign
too we I can't do I can do one for one
okay
okay
who wants sheep
wants Rock
for first sheep what
I love you like these times
one two three
oh and then at the road building
okay cool
good night everybody
for a good night see you later green tea
four
four
yeah
oh [ __ ]
like of course anybody need break
seven
oh I'll smack out
foreign
people have wheat
no
I do what do you have two ores I'll give
you a breaking a sheet for a week
do you do I have any ore or any sheep
really
you can't do that it doesn't make sense
I'll give you or for a week
straight up but you would do it for an
ore and a sheep
[Laughter]
that would be my favorite thing to do
right
don't you think I don't wish I could
so you don't have a tree
or uh does anyone have a sheep damn
knock this monster I'll give an ore to
someone who has a sheep
nah Silence from the crowd
no five six points
all right then perish
oh my gosh
what do you think about George Bush
foreign
not even women
and then they were like oh he's dead
wow it says right before you go remember
you're an [ __ ]
oh
now
[Music]
is that 11.
actually like that
Jesus Christ Dane you got to build roads
four turns ago
you gotta take her along this road
he's getting scary
yeah
he's a guy hey
Salman
yeah I've got brick and [ __ ] to trade
for trees
that's all I got
told my mom was about a home loser
thank God
he got me there
who wants she
no two sheep for one week
whoa you know I wish I could
Health accessory you wish you could do
it but you can't do it
just tell him you wish you could just be
like I'm really like
I pray about it I can but I also keeps
me up at night
God damn it eight
I'm the only one that has an eight right
now
blocked hard
knock hard
and for for four of anything I can then
pick what I want yeah okay
oh actually you're on a port too for uh
for wheat so if you have two wheat you
can do any you could be any card as well
it's hard to come by these days there
you go yeah I mean you got three right
it's not right so that means I want to
calm down burrito
all right come on
we
where do I want
a
tree
um so the commenters
corresponding they say
this is the weirdest game of two-headed
giant I've ever seen
two-headed what
Hans the only person I know to buy those
glasses
that's not true a lot of eighth graders
have to buy these glasses for their
science lab requirements
very true
what is the two-headed dragon thing I
don't know I think yeah it's trying yeah
to the professionals well hey guys we
don't have to coach this guy right yeah
he's just a [ __ ] board I didn't let
go of it though
chest rolls leave the jokes to the
professionals guys which that's us you
know yeah we'll say the jokes speak for
yourself
I'm quitting comedy I'm out of this
[ __ ] five five
Jesus Christ [ __ ] look how many cards
this [ __ ] has
uh damn
well nothing I can [ __ ] use
apparently
do you mind putting that one over there
on the brick port
it's only had any Wheat
so
you got any weight
wheat Hans no sugar cane deals I'm not
trading with you
I'm I'm really not going to win this
one's borders so
this has got to get that longest road
man how much more do I need if I were
you I'd be sure
they're saying this because they want to
try to win and they want to bring you
down with them
no I just don't want you to win exactly
how much how many more how many more
roads do I need in here two more okay
yeah I mean it's what they're saying is
they'll divide and you're a martyr in
this situation so yeah I mean you can
listen to them or you could listen to
your heart since 789
you need three more it's an uphill
battle I don't think it's gonna happen
for you what about this thing
that's a secret oh
I'm like
I'm watching this mind manipulation
things
you know
I used the night of Nazareth
I slayeth the dragon that is the
tazai
okay it was seven points yeah who's who
else has a lot of points Dylan Dylan's
in second place nice well your real
threat is this guy he's brown I only
have four points I'm not gonna block
myself I'd be a heathen to do it that
and I will take from Sir Dillon where
she will
with respect
it's a dead end of delivery just feels
better
development
okay
that's right
go away
goeth with God
oh Timmy keyboard I don't think he's
lying
seven uh influence
foreign
[Music]
you can change your mind until you touch
them
okay hope you're happy
11 11 11 11 11 11 11 11 11 11 11 11.
five
numbers
foreign
nights
modern
good point they're all the same
someone said I bet big dude smashes
I love that it's awesome
smash it if we're talking about Super
Smash Brothers
so cool
that's pretty good
okay well I like staying on as long as
possible until I pass out like it's a
chore
this is hard but I can do it
we all got this
okay
what are you doing
it's getting a death car there's not
much I can do
how many night cars do you have over
there five speaking of which I you this
the night of also done oh my God and I
use it tonight on
um
I only have six points
and I use this night on Sir Dylan and
Hans
and I take
why he's winning
I'm really not it's got two victories
you have eight years he has more cards
on the board
you have two
cars Max
six
who wants wood
Three Wood fur right now
three Woods her right weight I need
weight
Rock for wheat
Rock for uh wood
Ed your roll-ons
uh six okay
yeah nice
um I will take
who's what who has the top points
because I think Hans or no it's Kareem I
think Dom has nine all right Kareem
what's up bro let me see what you got
where'd you move I would like rather uh
[Music]
it's just custom area right here oh
perfect thanks for letting me know
um I'll take something from you
I would like a brick you know you don't
have to do it can you Shuffle it I'm
gonna take the far right and can that be
brick please feel free to shuffle
okay
trust you
that's it's funny I had one thing
that's so cool
interesting strategy telling your
opponent your move
[Music]
this is only because of your smirk right
now okay
yes I would
it's because of my Smurf yeah it's not
even for gameplay
yeah at that there's a certain point or
you just gotta accept things
seven oh
get the [ __ ] out of here oh no he's mad
at me oh no you can't take it okay
you guys are all going against me
four eight five
stop doing five
I keep rolling five
somebody fives
who wants wood or brick
I need wheat
who wants sheep or brick or rock for
what I mean wheat or away
they need brick but I don't have weed
I've yeah
you know
do you have
two or I have one or what about three
sheep perfect I have one sheep
HD nice dude
it's white
did a good thing right there yeah I
didn't forget this get out of here
seriously
cheers
no I need freaking trains
[ __ ] mother I have a sheep and I have
or I don't know that was worth three
months at least yeah
you know
kick them out
from
uh no you rolled seven so
discarding okay 30 cards
he's flying the next attack
that's a cat
um
Kareem yeah
oh yeah good news not bad news
good news is
rapist
that's a good news
you should you're not going to want to
hear the bandage it's like Mari
[Music]
in All Rights
uh
uh
use this development card
S I wish you wouldn't have built over
there I was gonna try that smash the
longest road
um are you hiding I wouldn't have been
able to yeah
all right are you hiding cards
was I hiding cards
oh yeah
where do you want these
um can I get one going from 10-5
[Laughter]
but the guy in the shirt he probably is
referring to me okay
the powers
the gay and the shirt is hiding gun
the shirtless guy
cannot hide wait we should start having
your shirt
who do we know
I don't know if we know anybody
do we even know ourselves no sure I
don't even know we're offered like a
movie all the lifetime yeah okay
I knew you're gonna see us today I just
had to know the extent of it the weather
you would say yesterday on a film you
did yeah the guy on that side of the
table is cheating why don't they just
say
the weather balloon
behind the Katan screen move it so you
can see
stop listening don't don't listen I was
gonna say oh he's hiding cards behind
the screen oh okay
he's making us do the hokey pokey I know
they're trying to make a Witch Hunt we
have to get up early for your Microsoft
do they even have a weave for Brick
no two bread for one week
no no
it's [ __ ] up man I feel like you guys
are against me or something because you
got because you're in the lead
seven all right
Anywhere But Here oh yes perfect
so Dylan has seven cream has eight yeah
how many development cards you have he's
got a lot he's got two
how many cards do you have
many this one
four not many
um
he's gonna have to go with he's
literally in the lead house and I I
really don't I'm really not taking this
I swear he has more than four but if you
want to you
look how many he has
a ton
it is
loose for once
hey great
yeah
oh World fives every time
you're a five guy I'm a five guy
hey uh I have sheep and or I need brick
I got you for whatever don't trade
everything he's running oh no actually I
won't change eight points
no actually I need my mind I won't trade
it yet
what was that it was uh
seven
oh my God so if you have a cell phone
player
dude this sounds so nice right now I
think
it's too important
remember the rolls
you gotta take for me oh my God
you have those last before I was like
this guy's cool man
show
sorry it was all for game
it's a nasty business
yeah these games are long
what is it what was it seven
I rolled a seven oh really yeah what's
new oh [ __ ]
oh
that was you made it personal
you went from the left yeah
Wes thank you sir
goodbye Nathan
yes I do mean reverse psychology
clockwise I counterclockwise psychology
that's a good one
is that what that this that's what this
meant
exactly
yeah it would be cool to have a laser
engraved guitar on board dude what are
those like a really nice one what do
those look like this one's pretty sick
you know like when you used to engrave
iPods yeah like that like it's just
metal
hand
that's pretty wild that would be cool
yeah that would be cool
this is not colorful you can kind of see
the differences between them with it you
guys remember hearing as kids that they
had a monopoly set though
used real money and like the board was
gold or the dyes were golden that sounds
like a kid story it does sound like a
kid story but I think it I think it
might have been real really maybe they
would know
but for at least rumors
where that there's this Monopoly board
that you could buy and all the money was
real
and then all the pieces were like gold
and silver oh
rooms and [ __ ] and the elites would play
it and set up regular Monopoly
hey did you get a fun call yeah [ __ ]
well good because we're gonna [ __ ] on
you too
and he took from me God can you believe
it
all right thank you I want to review
myself for your eyes
are you gonna build this longest road
honestly Dean everything they've been
saying I don't know how to tell you this
it's been a lot they're just bullying
you yeah I just like I have to say
because I can't buy it
and thanks
foreign
[Music]
can I have
trees can I have wood I have ore and I
have sheep
lots of ore amen what do you need one
ore for one tree please actually no I
don't play with your kind
um
I'll do it
uh-huh bam thank you Hans please
yes
it's a road and belt initiative I'm
funding foreign
good job Dan thank you sir
anybody else want a tree I mean you can
give me a tree for or sheep
you have tree no I need tree I need tree
no I have ore lots of it
I could give you a
the new or a [ __ ]
sheep too
good
honest sheets
or she working
these sheeps are oars all of them
no I I uh I don't uh well you I have one
wood
yeah yeah but I need to I need two if I
had two wood I wouldn't do it if I get a
wood on this on on this roll then I'll
tell you and give me one I don't need
two I just need one wood
but what do you have I have you have a
[ __ ] but that's I I don't I'm not on a
port or anything and I got a bunch of
ore too
just past the dies
that's that's true that's Hans means
he's circling it on the win
I'm so far from it
[ __ ]
four I doubt it these out each count is
a pointer now
you're all the four yeah
uh how many more freaking things do I
need till I can get my
longest road
can't really do anything Tom wins a
grind
it's not for the faint of heart too
all right
just um
we're all tied at seven does anyone want
to trade me a stone
for what
for nothing
all right
Mr T's pants did anyone hear something
11.
yeah I heard this there we go
11's been called a lot this round yeah
it's been good
Hans why have you not taken it yet
I feel like you got you have to at least
have a victory point or something
yeah
the game lots of ore
o okay okay everyone give me your wheat
I don't think you can do that
do that wait
is there we have we actually have this
week I have no we
Ed
[ __ ] I'm sorry
good night unemployed
how many more freaking roads do I need
to get longer throat
you do have the victory point he needs
one more point I win
there you go
what the [ __ ] how'd you win we have the
victory point I don't see a victory
point in the army
yeah
we got a second I was actually gonna
cheat my way to Victory because I had
nine points but I really only had seven
points because you have the longest road
but I still have it technically
it's like Palestine nobody recognizes it
well I said I was like when do I get
that over and I just you just kept
sitting there ignore I was like all
right I guess not now
Hans do you do podcast episodes in here
yeah
yeah I've been trying to
running I haven't been hearing anything
ones they're even better yeah they are
I do enjoy this we haven't done it in a
while have you been doing Catan lately
honestly no not a lot I've been playing
online a lot let's ramp it up yeah
you've been doing colonists what we need
to do is do it every at a certain time
every week on Monday
maybe like Tuesdays at like three
yeah like a day thing yeah yeah that
could be cool
no this time works when do you go to LA
I go tomorrow
what time is it 3 A.M already
yeah no it's I think it's two 150. let's
see 150. oh my God yeah it does feel
pretty six hours oh [ __ ] so are you just
uh
are you staying up
no it's gonna take a little nap
okay I'll put the rest back
let me put more this away yeah that's
fine okay thanks everyone for staying
here
bye